dangerous and lethal strains of the
coronavirus are spreading across the
globe
overwhelming health care systems
some are close to collapse
who has warned that the covet-19 virus
continues to change
so far
four variants of concern have emerged
and there will be more as long as the
virus continues to spread
as the worst case scenario the british
scientific advisory group for
emergencies fears a potential future
variant could be far more deadly than
existing ones
they could even evade current vaccines
one day
it appears the total eradication of the
virus will be unlikely
but how can we live with its constant
mutation
[Music]
welcome to your kovid 19 special here on
dw i'm jenelle dumalaon
over the past few weeks indonesia became
the epicenter of the pandemic in asia at
one point peaking at more than 50 000
cases per day while the worst seems to
have passed case numbers remain very
high and indonesia's health ministry
says the number of coveted infections
among fully vaccinated medical workers
in the capital jakarta has been rising
with most of them catching the delta
variant our reporter risky putra sent us
the story
getting into her covid protective gear
takes some time and more than a little
courage
but nurse desanti is just glad to have
equipment available
right after graduating from nursing
school last year she was sent to the
front line of the pandemic in jakarta
and became infected herself
a few months after she recovered the
second wave hit the country
we use stretchers wheelchairs
we even had to rotate the oxygen bottles
for patients in the emergency room
and they kept coming and coming even
after we were out of beds and oxygen
those who came had low oxygen levels i
was overwhelmed
the intensive care unit at this hospital
is still at full capacity even though
case numbers in the capital have been
decreasing
officially covid has claimed more than a
hundred thousand lives in indonesia with
many health workers among the victims
they've mostly been given the chinese
cinevac vaccine
now medical staff like dr puspita are
getting a booster shot of moderna to
better protect them
this is just me but when there are a lot
of cases i start talking to myself this
is insane i have to work with covet 19
cases over and over
i often feel like crying but then i
realize i'm not alone my colleagues are
also working hard
doctors and nurses fully support the
strict lockdown measures that the
indonesian government has enforced to
flatten the curve
in jakarta roads have even been blocked
to reduce mobility
only those with the proper papers like
health workers are allowed to pass
for weeks jakarta's big shopping malls
remain closed except for supermarkets
the malls will reopen in late august but
only to people with vaccination
certificates
a trial program has already started
according to dad from jakarta state
hospitals the mortality rate during this
second wave has been almost four times
higher for the unvaccinated than for
those with two shots
please get the vaccine while you can get
free access
whatever vaccine it is take it because
it helps us fight the virus
please obey health protocols and put
your mask on
there are still many people out there
who do not wear their mask correctly
desantis family are very proud of their
daughter
they belong to the 18 percent of the
population who've had one dose of the
vaccine
only eight percent are fully vaccinated
and while the rate of infections may be
falling in jakarta
the delta variant is now threatening
indonesia's poorly equipped regions
we're now joined by penny moore a
virologist at the university of the
witwatersrand and the south african
national institute for communicable
diseases she is speaking to us from
johannesburg welcome to the program
first off we've now become familiar with
vaccinated people being hit by the delta
variant how well do vaccines work
against the variant
uh they work fairly well against the
variant
it depends how you define protection and
to some extent it depends on the on the
vaccine the bottom line is that all the
vaccines that we have do provide
protection against delta but it is
slightly reduced protection for example
compared to what we would have seen
against the original variant or against
alpha
it also depends how you define
protection all the vaccines do a very
good job
at preventing hospitalization and death
and probably that's the most important
thing to think about from a public
health perspective
protection from infection is a slightly
more nuanced issue
now we were told that the more we
vaccinate the closer we get to herd
immunity but since delta can break
through despite vaccination what kind of
impact has delta had on our expectations
of herd immunity
yeah delta unfortunately delta because
of its incredibly high transmissibility
compared to previous variants is a whole
new challenge for us
it is fortunately susceptible to
antibodies both those triggered by a
previous infection and those triggered
by vaccines
but it's it's complicated because the
higher rate of transmission means that
you're balancing these two things so
so although
we can get vaccines out and we can get
as many people vaccinated as possible we
are facing this huge force of infection
in south africa where i'm based the
entire epidemic now is virtually only
delta in south africa
so i think that's testament and it's
another example of several countries
where
where deltas come to dominate but i
think it's important to understand that
um the vaccines do prevent infection do
prevent hospitalization and even in the
case of breakthrough infections
the severity of the illness caused by
the delta variant is reduced in
vaccinated individuals and the rate at
which they transmit transmit the virus
to other individuals is also reduced
so is there a case for booster vaccines
to reduce the number of symptomatic
cases among vaccinated people
this is a major question in the field um
to my mind it's
it's it's certain that at some point we
will require boosters
at some point in the future all of us
regardless of the vaccine that we've
been
vaccinated with we will require boosters
but the question is really when that
will be and what that booster will look
like at this stage we're only beginning
now to get a sense of what the
correlative protection is
and what i mean by that is we're only
beginning to understand how much
antibody is enough
to consider a person or population
protected and we really need more
information about that and it'll also
depend to some extent on what the
variants are that continue to emerge
because they will continue to emerge
now speaking of that i'm sure a lot of
our viewers are wondering what comes
after delta what do we know about the
lambda variant
yeah the lander variant
was in the news quite a lot recently it
very much dominated the epidemic in peru
and a few other south american countries
it does show some
evidence of increased resistance to
neutralizing antibodies so it has some
of the same or similar mutations to what
we're used to seeing in variance concern
that make these variants
able to evade the immune
it also shows some
evidence of increased transmissibility
but i think it's important to point out
that i don't think there's to my
knowledge there's not an example of a
place where delta is present
i mean out completed by lambda
thank you penny moore a virologist at
wits university and the national
institute for communicable disease she
spoke to us from johannesburg
thank you
now to an interesting question on the
delta variant one for science
correspondent derek williams to answer
what makes people with the delta variant
so much more contagious
in trying to answer this i think that we
first need to go back to a term that
once got a lot of air time but that many
of you have probably
since forgotten and and that's the basic
reproduction number of a pathogen or
it's are not now the r naught describes
the average number of people that an
infected person will infect in turn
in an unexposed
unvaccinated population
when it first hit
the ancestral coronavirus had an r
naught of around two to three so
each infected person on average infected
two to three others
but the original virus has since mutated
into a range of variants among them the
delta variant and and it's a lot more
transmissible with an are not
that's estimated to be twice as high or
or maybe even higher
of course
a lot more people are now largely immune
to the virus due to vaccination or
previous infection so
each new delta patient isn't actually
infecting twice as many others but still
people who get the delta variant are a
lot more contagious than those who have
other variants of the virus
so what exactly has raised the r naught
in the delta variant well
researchers think that two changes in
particular are probably behind its
increased transmissibility the first
involves a set of mutations that they
say have altered the structure of the
spikes
that dot the outer surface of the virus
the spikes are what allow the virus to
latch on to receptors
on a cell's outer membrane and break
into it and and scientists believe that
changes to the delta variant spikes have
made that break-in process easier
the second change involves how much of
the virus is being produced by cells
one study found
that delta variant patients had viral
loads that were around a thousand times
higher than what's found in those
infected with the original virus
with that massive replication also
possibly happening a lot faster
all of those factors scientists think
are contributors to making the delta
variant one of the most infectious
respiratory diseases out there
[Music]
you